naja ich hab ja auch in dieser sendung
schon gesagt ich finde diese
entscheidung jetzt aus humanitären
gründen eine kleine gruppe von menschen
aufzunehmen die besonders hilfsbedürftig
ist richtig und trotzdem halte ich es
unverändert für notwendig dass wir eine
einheitliche europäische regeln haben
wir haben regeln die gelten die griechen
halten sich an diese regeln
wir haben kein verteilen mechanismus das
ist ein großes problem
aber solange der genialen aber er weiß
ich muss es einfach deswegen noch einmal
sagen und deswegen halte ich auch eine
strikte begrenzung des zuzugs nach
deutschland für richtig verstehen die
leute die jetzt sagen gerade wenn man
diese schicksale wie das von handys sie
sagen es da sind noch ganz viele
schwerster noch ganz viele brüder dass
die jetzt einmal sagen leute wir haben
wir sind ganz großzügig aber jetzt sind
wirklich einfach die anderen dran
die stimmung in der bevölkerung ist klar
und eindeutig die große mehrheit der
deutschen will nicht mehr zuzug so und
ich bin mit dieser meinung dass wir das
im augenblick nicht leisten können und
wir brauchen gemeinsame analysen
gemeinsame europäische regeln wissend
dass wir sie im augenblick ob der lage
nicht bekommen